[Musique]
en 2010 neuf 2340 dépôt de plainte pour
violences conjugales ont été enregistrés
ces chiffres en augmentation place la
réunion au troisième rang des régions
les plus touchées par ce fléau
depuis plusieurs années le département a
fait de cette lutte une priorité parmi
les mesures du plan d'action contre ce
fléau un partenariat état département a
été signée en 2005
objectif le cofinancement de postes
d'intervenants sociaux en commissariat
et en gendarmerie
le dispositif qui fait que dans un même
espace en l'occurrence très commissariat
de police par exemple vous allez
retrouver au personnel de police en
l'occurrence des enquêteurs mais aussi
des personnels chargés de l'accueil du
public et enfin les yers cgc des
assistantes sociales dont le financement
est 50% et à 50% pour débarquement et
qui désormais sont vainement intégré
dans le mode de fonctionnement afin
d'appréhender avec la grande qualité
nécessaire les victimes de violences et
notamment des femmes victimes de
violences ce partenariat donne aux
femmes victimes de violences les moyens
d'être prises en charge à différents
niveaux
quand on se retourne et qu'on regarde
pas ce qu'il y avait derrière nous dans
sa personne tout le chemin parcouru et
ce chemin parcouru il a été parcouru
grâce à notamment au travail partenarial
avec le département avec l'état avec les
mairies mais aussi surtout avec le
milieu associatif et qui permet
maintenant dans le cadre de l'accueil
notamment des femmes victimes d'avoir
une prise en compte total de ces femmes
à la fois en tant que victimes mais
aussi sur le plan juridique
sur le plan social depuis la mise en
place également la chaîne pénale qui
s'est faite la journée internationale
pour l'élimination des violences faites
aux femmes a été l'occasion de faire un
point d'étape
d'ores et déjà c'est vrai que nous
avions à l'époque quatre à cinq
travailleurs sociaux aujourd'hui nous en
sommes à 8 bientôt neuf et à terme ce
sont 15 intervenants qui seront en poste
c'est 15 intervenants et bien fort parti
de toute l'équipe dédiée à
l'accompagnement des personnes
fragilisées par les violences
intrafamiliales si l'écouté
l'accompagnement des victimes est un
point essentiel du plan d'action
département
al la collectivité a également renforcé
l'accueil d'urgence finances
effectivement des structures
d'hébergement
on a conventionné également avec des
pensions des gîtes des hôtels au pouvoir
accueillir quand effectivement n'a pas
de classe dans ces structures mais on a
également aussi conventionnés auprès des
taxiteurs voilà pour pouvoir permettre
en fait le la prise en charge la femme
est de pouvoir la mener dans son 120
dans son dos d'hébergement
[Musique]